Good morning or
good afternoon,
depending on wherever you are
on the globe when you
are watching this.
My name is Frank van Harmelen,
and I would like
to discuss with
you in the next half hour AI
systems that learn
and reason.
So first, let's take a,
a broader look at at where I
where modern AI is is going.
So here are are
just two quotes
from from recent
blogs and from
the web page of
recent AI centers
that have been initiated.
And they all talk about making
artificial intelligence more
human centered,
making AI systems that support
people and that are
competent partners.
So the emphasis
in modern AI is
is less on replacing,
people by AI systems,
but more on AI systems that
collaborate with people and
support them.
But at the same time,
here's another quote
from a popular
blog, current AI systems are
often incompetent because they
lack background and,
and contextual knowledge,
and they cannot even explain
their actions.
And so, clearly,
current AI systems with their
lack of background
knowledge and
and their lack of contextual
knowledge and their lack of
ability to explain
themselves,
they are not very
human centered,
and they cannot
support people,
and they cannot be
competent partners.
Right. So, what's
holding AI back?
Right. So why are
we in the situation
where, on the one hand,
we would like to build systems
that support and collaborate
with people, but on
the other hand,
our systems are
somehow incompetent
and they lack
background knowledge
and contextual knowledge about
the tasks that we
ask them to do.
And, a a common analysis these
days is that what's holding AI
back is that for a long time,
AI researchers have locked
themselves into one
of two towers.
Now we all know
the famous story
of the two towers. Right?
And, in the case of AI,
we could call
these the symbolic
AI tower and
the statistical AI tower.
And as as always in a kingdom
with with two towers,
one tower thinks
that the other
tower is evil and
that they are
wrong and that you should not
really discuss,
with with them.
You should even
fight them maybe.
And in fact,
maybe there's even
another analogy
that is appropriate
here, which is that AI was not
only divided as two
towers, but maybe,
you know, people even had sort
of different religions about
what AI should be.
You could either be
of the statistical
AI religion, in which case you
would build neural
networks, and train,
machine learning programs,
or you were of
the symbolic AI,
religion, in which case you
would build knowledge bases,
you would build
very large large
models graphs, and you do
inference over them.
And just as with
religions, you know,
statistical AI
and symbolic AI,
they had their own books,
they had their own meetings,
and you didn't really need to
talk to each other
because, you know,
the other people
were wrong anyway.
And fortunately,
I I think in
the last few years,
we are beginning to see in AI
an increasing
movement that these,
these two different
streams in AI,
they are beginning to talk to
each other, and
they are beginning
to understand,
that we actually
need them both
because our brain
uses both. Right?
Our brain does
both the the stuff
that that machine
learning is good at,
and it does the stuff that
knowledge representation
is good at.
So here is, a very
rough sketch
of what's going
on in our brain
when we look at
an image. Right?
So here's a a cross cutting of
somebody's brain.
They're looking out
towards the right.
It's their eye.
So what happens when,
light hits the retina?
Well, when light
hits the retina,
of course, there
is the optical
nerve that go to
the visual cortex.
Right? We call this
the the bottom
up signal. Right?
And this this
bottom up signal,
when it hits
the visual cortex,
the visual cortex
analyzes, forms,
shapes. It it
recognizes separate
objects. It
recognizes motion.
It recognizes object
of conclusion,
and, it interprets the scene.
And these signals
then go to our
prefrontal cortex,
where we have,
memory, where we do planning,
where we do problem solving.
But interestingly
enough, in our brain,
there is also
a downstream signal.
Namely, the prefrontal cortex
is continuously
telling the visual
cortex what to expect.
So it's not just a matter of
the pixels feeding
the symbolic
representation,
it's also a matter
of the symbolic representation
telling the pixel processors,
what to expect and how to
interpret all these pixels.
And in fact, without
such a downstream
signal, our visual
cortex would
never be fast
enough to interpret
all the visual signals
that come in.
And, and actually,
the downstream nerves,
are actually larger
than the upstream.
So there is
a a constant traffic
up and down between
the symbolic
and the statistical
parts of our brain,
if you allow me that,
that freedom.
So now we could
call the upstream
signal data driven,
as in neural networks,
machine learning,
and we call
the the downstream,
signal knowledge driven.
And, actually, the history of
AI also shows this.
It it is not the case
that the history
of AI in the past,
we did symbolic stuff,
and now we realize
that the symbolic
stuff was, wrong or
somehow mistaken.
And now we are
seeing the light
and we're doing neural
networks and and,
we're making good progress.
The actual history of AI has
been a constant
pendulum between
these two streams,
and frequency of this pendulum
is about a decade.
And, and certainly
in the last decade,
we have seen large major
breakthroughs in
the the the connectionist
data driven
statistical machine
learning, part of AI.
But we have also
seen important,
scale up, in
the the symbolic,
and knowledge
based logic driven
and reasoning part of AI.
And, we are now
seeing the pendulum
swinging back to the middle of
this spectrum,
and, hopefully,
we can this time,
we managed to
stop the pendulum
somewhere in
the middle so that
we can combine these two.
Now to put a little bit more
flesh on this comparison,
now let's compare,
these two streams of AI,
and and here is a a table that
that very briefly
compares the strength
and and weaknesses of AI.
So let me go through
this table.
So first of all,
the the construction
costs. Right?
So as we know,
symbolic AI and and
for this, audience,
you are all very familiar with
with very large model graphs.
These very large
knowledge graphs,
they are, not they are large.
They contain billions of facts
and rules,
but they are
expensive to build
and expensive to maintain.
So either
through crowdsourcing
or through corporate,
investments.
Right, but they are expensive
to build at midday.
But the connectionist approach
also has its
construction costs
and here the construction cost
is called data hunger.
So many of you
will be familiar
with the Nvidia
benchmark where
Nvidia scraped, millions of,
faces of people
from the Internet
and trained the neural network
to generate new faces. Right?
Now the neural network is so
good that that humans can no
longer distinguish
between real
faces and and
generated faces,
but it took ten
million training
samples to train
the network for this.
And, of course,
NVIDIA was very
clever in choosing
this domain because
for human faces,
we can actually
scrape ten million
training examples
from the web,
but now try to do
this for, say,
rare cancer tumors. Right?
So images of rare tumors.
You cannot obtain ten million
ten million training sample.
The same holds
for for AlphaGo.
You know, the famous,
DeepMind program that,
that beat the best,
human Go player in the world,
it took four point
eight million
training games,
mostly AlphaGo training
against itself.
And, again, game
playing is a domain
where you can basically,
you have infinite amounts of
training material.
And, again, this
is not true in
in most of
the the business cases,
that you would
meet in practice.
So I'm always a little
bit annoyed when,
machine learning people tell
their customers, well,
we can't really
help you because
you don't have enough data.
Well, it's not the case
of the customer
not having enough data.
The problem is
that the machine
learning algorithms
need too much data.
So you see that,
they have sort
of complementary
strengths and
weaknesses here.
And, as we know, these
symbolic methods,
they suffer from
the combinatorial
explosion. Right?
So they they get worse
with more data.
Right? This is called
the combinatorial
explosion. But the connection
is the neural
network approaches,
they get worse
with less data.
Right? So, they
they suffer from
this data hunger.
So again, very complimentary
strength and weaknesses.
Another, you know,
by now well
known complementary
strength and
weakness of the two
systems are their
explainability.
These symbolic systems,
they have the advantage that
their vocabulary is very close
to the vocabulary
that people,
everyday people
or experts, use.
So here is a rule
about a particular
medical system, sim
a medical symptom,
dysphagia, which,
then causes,
some, a particular
conclusion,
namely a medical
diagnosis. Right?
So we have a variable,
we have a condition,
we have a conclusion,
and this is in
an understandable format.
And, as we all know,
these neural networks
don't have this.
Here's a famous example from
the literature
where researchers
took a neural network that,
with reasonable confidence,
recognized this
picture as a panda,
and then they added noise to
the picture, noise that is
invisible to the human eye,
and suddenly,
the picture
the the neural network
recognized the picture
as a given.
Now you would
want to know what
went wrong, what
happened between
this one picture and the other
picture when we can't even see
the difference.
Now what
the the neural network
engineers did is
they carefully
added noise from
the picture of a given,
and they carefully
drove the network
down into another
local minimum
in the high dimensional,
fitness landscape
where the network
training does
gradient descent.
Okay. Now that's clearly not
an explanation
that you can give
to to any reasonable user of
such a network of
of such a neural
network. So this is known as
the black box problem.
And finally, as we well know,
symbolic systems suffer from
what's called
the performance cliff.
Think again of
a knowledge graph.
If you query
the knowledge graph
for facts that are
in the knowledge
graph, you get very
high quality,
you know, both
precision and recall.
But if you start
querying it for
stuff that is outside
the knowns graph,
basically, you get
no answer. Right?
So there's a very
steep performance
cliff. But, also,
these connectionist
approaches,
they suffer from
a a performance cliff.
Right? Here's a famous
example from,
an an an image
labeling competition
a few years ago, and
the question was,
what is this lady
wearing on our head?
And the answer was with near
hundred percent certainty,
she's wearing a shower cap.
Now, we all know that this is
not a shower cap,
because we recognize this lady
and we know that
she's the queen,
and we know what
queens do with
shower caps, they don't wear
them in public,
so so this cannot possibly be
a shower cap. Why
does the system
think this is a shower cap?
Well, probably in
the training set,
there were not very many,
training examples of ladies
wearing tiaras,
wearing crowns.
And maybe there were examples
of of people wearing
shower caps.
So this is a typical case of
an out of sample very poor out
of sample generalizability.
That's the performance
cliff of
connection systems.
So if we then see that these
systems have complementary
strengths and weaknesses,
can we somehow get
them to collaborate?
And and just to
emphasize, you know,
this is this performance cliff
is is not an an an artificial
example.
Here are all reasonable stop
signs as you would
find them in
practice. Some
funny guy has put
a sticker on it or there is
funny shape shadows on it,
and these are all
recognized as
a maximum speed limit sign.
So this is clearly
a realistic problem.
So can we solve such realistic
problems with
the machine learning
systems by getting them to
collaborate with
the symbolic systems?
Right? That's what
what the rest
of the talk is
going to be about.
Can we get
the symbolic systems,
the systems that reason,
and the subsymbolic systems,
the systems that learn,
can we collaborate,
can we get them to collaborate
in a system that both
learn and reasons?
And I will give
you a number of
examples of systems
that do such
a collaboration.
So maybe to this community,
the best example,
the easiest example
is using a learning
system to enrich
a knowledge graph.
This is often called knowledge
graph completion.
So imagine that we
have a knowledge
graph about music,
and we have many links between
artists and songs.
We know that, Michael Jackson
published Beat It,
and we know that the Beatles
published Yesterday,
and we know etcetera.
So we have many links between
artists and, and their songs,
and we that that has
a particular label,
namely that that artist has
published that song.
Now if we take this knowledge
graph and we,
somehow transform
this knowledge
graph into a high dimensional
vector space where,
similarity in the knowledge
graph corresponds
to similarity
in the vector space,
then Michael Jackson
would become
a vector. The song
Beat It would
become a vector.
And the relationship between
Michael Jackson and beat it,
namely the relationship
publish,
is also a vector,
from the between
the two endpoints.
And now we might
recognize that
if we have a vector
for the Rolling
Stones and a vector
for Angie,
that the distance
between the Rolling
Stones and Angie
is very similar
to the distance
between Michael
Jackson and Beatit.
So this may cause
us to learn that,
the relationship
between Rolling
Stones and Angie
is the same as
between Michael
Jackson and Beat It,
namely, it's the relation
published this all. Right?
So in this way,
we can learn new facts to add
to another graph
by using machine
learning methods in this high
dimensional vector space.
So, essentially,
now what we are doing here,
we are are taking a graph
representation. We are turning
it into a real vector
representation,
a high dimensional,
real real number vector
representation.
We do machine learning
in the vector
space, which leads to new
predictions of links,
and we translate
these new links
back to the, to
the symbolic space.
Right? So sometimes
we call this
this this pattern,
we call it from
symbols to data
and back again.
So we started with symbols,
the the knowledge graph.
We produced some data space.
We did machine
learning on the data
space, and we
translated it back
to the symbolic space.
So this is one
combination where
we use learning
systems to improve
the symbolic systems.
So there, we were using,
learning systems to
rule only facts.
Right? So we could
learn new facts,
but there are also
systems where
we learn new rules.
And these, learning
systems are
called inductive
logic programming
systems or rule
mining systems.
So, here's an example from
inductive logic programming.
Suppose that we have
a knowledge base,
a knowledge base
in symbolic form,
this could be
a knowledge graph
about parental relationships.
And we know that,
and we can learn,
from this parent
and this parent,
father, and mother
relationships.
From this, we can
learn the rule
that when that
somebody is a parent,
if somebody is
either the father
or the mother of
that person. Right?
So parent x y if either mother
x y or father x y.
So we can learn
these new rules.
Now we can confront the system
with a new fact,
namely father,
Carrie, Andy.
And together with,
this learned knowledge,
we can now derive
that not only
is Carrie the father
of Andy, but,
Carrie must also be
the parent of Andy.
And this can also
be done on on
knowledge graphs.
AnyBurl, from, Manheim,
is a system that, learns,
rules over knowledge graphs
rather than just
simple facts.
And this doesn't
only work on,
toy examples like the one that
I'm showing you here,
but this has also
been shown to
work on realistic
examples where
we take a, knowledge
graph about
chemical facts,
biochemical facts,
and the scientists
this is an example
from University of Leuven,
where the scientists,
the biochemists wanted to know
which parts of a chemical
structure makes a,
a molecule biologically
active or not.
And so some molecules are
biologically active, like,
and some are not.
So, for example,
Petrol is
biologically active,
but plastic is
biologically very
inactive. But they
are both made
of very similar, molecules.
And by feeding
the system examples
of molecules and labeling them
as biologically
active as as in
and inactive,
according to what
chemists know,
the system could
learn the rule
that this
substructure that you
see here on the right,
this substructure
is responsible
for a a a molecule being
biologically active or not.
So in all of
the examples we've
seen so far are examples of
where a learning
system improves
a symbolic system.
But we can also
turn this the other
way around.
So we can also use a knowledge
system to improve
a learning system.
Here's an example.
Let let's take
the previous example.
Now where now why
is this a crown?
Right? Why is this
a and and not
a a shower cap? K?
Now if we have
a neural network,
that, neural network
will generate
a whole set of hypotheses,
ranked with confidence.
And because of bad,
out of training,
set, generalizability,
the shower cap ended up with
the highest probability.
But if we now feed all these,
hypotheses, these possible
predictions into
a knowledge graph,
and the knowledge
graph can tell
us that there's a very close
relationship between queen and
crown with a very
long distance
relationship between queen and
shower cap, then the knowledge
graph will help us to select
the right hypothesis
and tell us that,
well, if we have to
choose between,
a crown and a shower cap,
then because this
is the queen,
it's more likely that this is
a crown and not a shower cap.
So here, we are
using a knowledge
based system to improve
the performance
of a machine learning system.
And we can use
almost the same,
setup, not only to
improve the output,
but also to improve
the explanations.
So suppose that by, you know,
whatever improvement we have
managed to get
the right output,
why is this a crown?
Hard for an image
labeling neural
network to explain
why this is a crown.
Right? This is just
a a large box,
a black box of neurons,
adding up to
the conclusion that
this is a crown.
So maybe we cannot give a real
explanation about the content
of the neural network,
why this is a crown,
but we can come up
with a reasonable
justification by using
an honest graph.
Right. Well, because
this is a queen,
what she's wearing on her head
is most likely
a crown. Right.
So we can use
a knowledge graph
to come up with
a justification for why,
machine learning
neural network,
produced a certain element.
Let me give you
another example.
Well, look at this picture.
What do you see here?
Now if you are
an image labeling
neural network,
how would you
label this image?
Well, you would say,
this is a flower.
Maybe you would
say it's a rose.
K? Well, actually,
you would have been wrong,
because if you would
know the context
of this picture,
you would see that
it's not a flower
or a rose. It's
actually a cushion.
Right? It's a cushion
on a chair.
So it's the context
that matters here.
Right? So what we can do is we
can take this picture.
Now let's assume that we have
already classified the object
in the blue bounding box,
namely that it's a chair.
Then we can inject
a little bit
of ontological knowledge.
The ontological
knowledge will tell us,
well, a chair is
made up out of
cushions and
an armrest. Right?
So, this is a simple bit of of
ontological knowledge.
If x is a chair and
y is part of x,
then y is either a cushion or
an armrest. Right?
Now given this bit
of ontological
knowledge plus the fact that
the blue bounding box
contains a chair,
that suddenly
increases the the
prior probability
of the cushion
as a as a an output,
and reduces
the prior probability
of flower as
an output. Output.
So the the prior
probability of
cushion given a chair is much
higher than
the prior probability
of a flower given a chair.
I mean, a flower is
not impossible.
It could still be
a flower lying
on the chair, but it's
much less likely.
So here, we are using a bit of
ontological knowledge to give
symbolic priors to
a subsymbolic,
object recognition, system.
And and, actually,
this is not
a a a a rare example.
There is a a very
good survey paper,
by, colleagues in two thousand
nineteen who,
surveyed more than a hundred,
different machine
learning systems
that use symbolic
priors to improve,
the behavior of
a machine learning
system. Now this is also known
as a symbolic loss function.
So so what is
a loss function?
A loss function
is the function
that you try to
minimize during
machine learning
training. Right?
It's the difference
between your
output and what your neural
network tells you.
And that difference between
the the between the desired
output and what your neural
system tells you,
you're trying to
minimize the difference
between the desired output and
the actual output.
Now it's part of the black art
of machine learning
to formulate
a correct loss function.
And there are many of these
systems in this
survey paper that,
use semantic loss functions.
So you write down
what you know
to be true about the world,
in this case, or
the parts of a chair,
and you are training
your system
so that it minimizes
the violation
of this background knowledge.
It minimizes
the conflicts between
what your system
says as output
and what you know is likely in
the world. So these semantic
loss functions
are a great help
to machine learning systems.
Here's another
nice example of,
of of the combination
of symbolic and,
and machine learning systems.
So this is an an exercise we
give to our first year machine
learning students. Right?
Train a neural network so that
it can read digits and then
produce the sum of the two
handwritten digits.
And you can do this
end to end training.
But somehow this is
not how we end up,
how we as humans
add up in, digits.
We don't add up
the visual images.
We abstract the visual images
into a symbolic
representation,
namely a number,
and then we add the numbers.
And, again,
an example from our
colleagues in
Leuven, in Leuven,
this is what they do.
Instead of adding up the two,
handwritten digits,
they first abstract
the handwritten
digits into a symbolic
representation,
namely, in this case,
the three and the five,
and then they add
the symbols,
rather than
training the system
to add up the how to add up to
handwritten digits.
So, yeah, this
is really cool,
and it colleagues
in London from,
UCL and,
and Google DeepMind to
train a reinforcement
learning agent in a very,
artificial world.
So in the the the agent was
moving around in
a world of objects,
but rather than making it move
in a world of pixels that are
perceived by
a neural network,
these pixels are
abstracted into
objects and then
the agent moves
around in this
world of objects,
rather than in this
world of pixels.
And what happened in
their experiments?
Well, this was a very simple
world where, you know,
the the the big
symbol in the middle
there, the plus,
is the agent,
and it had to move around in
this rectangle, this
grid like world.
It had to collect the crosses
and avoid the zeros. Right?
And, a reinforcement
learning agent,
the blue line, could could
perfectly learn this task in
this rectangular world.
And they also
trained an an agent
that moved around
in a world of
not in pixels, but abstracting
these crosses and nodes into
objects and then
move around in
the world of objects.
And that agent didn't
quite do so well.
But then they did
something interesting.
Then they they
changed the world.
They said, well,
now these objects
no longer live
on the grid world,
but these objects can live
anywhere in the world.
And then the performance of
the agent that was trained to
move around in
a world of pixels
completely degraded.
It it fell from
a hundred percent
to fifty percent
or less. Right?
But the agent that was moving
around in a world of objects,
it was stable in
its performance.
Now it could,
adjust to the fact
that these objects no longer
lived in a grid world,
but that these
objects could be
anywhere in the space,
and it was much more
robust to learning,
to adapting to
this new world.
Right? So, again,
a combination of
machine learning
and a symbolic representation
about the world.
Just as we don't
move around in
a world of pixels,
we we move around
in a world of
abstract objects
that we construct
out of the pixels.
The final example is about,
rule learning,
where in
the traditional world,
we would,
this is in a medical example
where we would feed patient
features about age and and,
and body mass index and blood
pressure and so on,
and then try to
predict, diabetes.
You could do this with,
with a a learning system,
and then the system would come
up with rules that
are are very good,
almost hundred
percent correct,
but that will be totally non
understandable by
medical experts.
And as a result,
even be though these
rules were correct,
the medical experts
don't really
like these systems
because they
can't understand
what they do.
So instead, what we
did in an experiment
jointly with,
University of Munich,
we injected, not only
data driven rules,
but we injected rules that we
obtained from experts and from
textbooks. And
these rules weren't
very difficult to, obtain.
We talked to experts.
We read some textbooks.
We read some medical
guidelines.
And the corresponding rule set
that you get out of combining
the human expert
knowledge with
the data driven rules
is almost as good,
interestingly enough,
not quite as good,
but almost as good
as the purely
data driven rules,
but the rules had became much
more human understandable.
So instead of a perfect system
that nobody uses,
you now have a slightly less
perfect system,
but that experts are
willing to use.
Let me for the sake of time,
I will skip
the the mathematics of this.
Right. So in the last
minute, my,
concluding remarks.
So what I have
tried to convince
you of is that
machine learning
systems can really
benefit from
injecting symbolic
knowledge in
in in many cases,
symbolic knowledge in the form
of knowledge graphs. Right?
We can produce better
explanations.
We can better
rank hypotheses.
We can do transfer learning.
We can get a better
sample efficiency,
so learn from fewer data.
And we can also
do this the other
way around. So we can have our
knowledge based
systems benefit
from machine
learning systems.
And the required symbolic
knowledge is available at very
large scale. Right?
It is no longer
true that symbolic
knowledge is expensive and we
cannot obtain it.
All the very large linked data
knowledge graphs are a witness
to the fact that this symbolic
knowledge is very
well available.
So it is no longer,
necessary to learn what you
already know. We can inject
the stuff that we already know
into our machine
learning systems,
and by combining
these two types
of systems, produce
much more robust,
much more efficient,
and much more
explainable systems.
Thank you very much.